literally just got back from Australia
like a matter of hours ago we love
Australia it's like hard to have a bad
time in Australia
flirting giggling staring Top Guns Glenn
Powell and euphoria's Sydney Sweeney
just turned up the heat on dating rumors
we did like so many activities uh Sydney
was like our social chair
Sydney who's reportedly engaged to
Jonathan devino shared pics of her
adventures filming anyone but you with
Glenn down under and Glenn's girlfriend
she unfollowed Sydney on Instagram after
this cozy couch video went viral the
on-screen couple worked their rom-com
chemistry on stage when Sydney jokes she
calls Glenn Top Gun he answered I love
when she calls me that
[Applause]
Oprah also hit the Vegas stage this
morning she interviewed the cast of The
Color Purple the Q a all part of
cinemacon a convention where Hollywood
builds Buzz about upcoming films to
theater owners and have you seen J Law's
new adult comedy So when you say date
him do you mean date him or date him in
no hard feelings Jennifer goes raunchy
letting the sex jokes fly it's
definitely an inappropriate comedy it's
R-rated it earns its R
um but it's it's funny
why you tried kidnapping me comedies are
so much better with with an audience
speaking of audiences Denzel Washington
got a standing ovation at the Sony
cinemacon presentation where he was
honored with the Lifetime Achievement
Award
this morning the trailer dropped for his
new movie The Equalizer 3 in theater
September 1st instead of Timex no it's
the median nerve that I'm compressing
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
now I noticed uh it said the Final
Chapter so this is the end huh and for
me it may not be the end they may do
another one but it's the end for me what
if it's like a massive check what if
it's a massive check yeah like a lot of
how much is a lot
how much is a lot go ahead you jumped
out there now if you were me how much
would you come back for
it would be a lot for his third time
around as Robert McCall the two-time
Oscar winner reportedly made 20 million
dollars Never Say Never but you never
know well these stars are all in on
voicing a sequel that's getting our
Spidey senses tingling there's so many
Easter eggs in this particular film I
feel so lucky to be a part of this
incredible cast of people
Haley Steinfeld and franchise newbie
Issa Ray are promoting Spider-Man across
the spider verse out June 2nd and Haley
gave us a health update on her Hawkeye
co-star Jeremy Renner I mean it is
could you get emotional talking about it
I still um
I'm so grateful that he's okay and he
has made a truly miraculous recovery
he's more than okay he's such a fighter
I mean I don't know if you guys know
this man but he is like the most
inspiring and not that I already didn't
feel that way about him
um I feel that way
times a million like he's amazing okay
ladies let's do this Issa Barbie movie
president Barbie
president Barbie there are theories out
there that there is some kind of Wizard
of Oz maybe connection there is kind of
a parallel there's kind of a pink brick
road I see where that theory is going I
receive it and I love the I continue to
theorize today Ken and Barbie Ryan
Gosling and Margot Robbie were in Vegas
hyping up the film Out July 21st but
speaking of parallels David Harbor can
definitely see the ones between Gran
Turismo his new film spawned by a video
game and this HBO hit I haven't played
in forever I've been loving Last of Us
they really killed it with that show did
you know Pedro Pascal
Kaiser kind of wow in the daddy verse
together I am your cool daddy we
occupy a certain Realm of the daddy the
realm yes yes
David and co-star Orlando Bloom will get
Hearts racing in their movie out August
11th and both hit the track those cars
are insanely powerful I'm wide awake and
coordination's coming up I know right
yeah my girl's gonna be soon that's fun
I'm not gonna make it there sadly but
but she's representing which is cool
that's cool I mean you got to be like
yeah it's cool she does those big
historical things it's wonderful she did
the she signed for the president too you
know she does that I mean but listen
who's who's there maybe the Pope
foreign